sie haben sich dafür gerade schon
angesprochen mit Sahra Wagenknecht
zusammen
dass Manifest verbindet sie beide gibt
es sonst etwas was sie beide verbindet
was haben sie gemeinsam also zunächst
mal wir haben uns vier wir sind uns vier
Tage vor Veröffentlichung des Manifestes
zum ersten Mal begegnet vorher haben wir
gemailt und gesoomt auch und
die Idee für das man ist fest
die ist ja erst Mitte Januar aufgekommen
da dachte ich es reicht es muss
irgendwas passieren und habe am 14
Januar Sarah Wagenknecht geschrieben und
am 15 habe ich gesagt wollen wir an
manife machen am 15 hat sie geantwortet
ja was verbindet uns warum habe ich
ausgerechnet ihr geschrieben weil mir
sie hat mir im Frühling geschrieben nach
dem offenen Brief den sie auch
unterzeichnet hat und dann haben wir
sehr locker schon mal alle ein zwei
Monate kleine Information ausgetauscht
mir ist einfach aufgefallen dass sie an
erster Stelle in diesem Land
der Mensch ist der der Mut hat offen
auch als Pazifistin also für den Frieden
kämpfend aufzutreten niemand hat so klar
und unerschüttert diese Position bezogen
auch gegen die eigene Partei die
Position von Sahra Wagenknecht ist ja
bekanntermaßen auch sehr umstritten in
ihrer Partei und da dachte ich jemand so
mutiges und außerdem sozusagen am
anderen Ende der Wurst ja also hier ist
die
unabhängige Feministin die ihr Leben
lang außer parlamentarischen Protest
gemacht hat ich war ja noch nie Mitglied
einer Partei da ist das unbequeme
Mitglied der LINKEN die auch sehr viel
riskiert und das dachte ich das müsste
sich eigentlich dann müsste es eine
Energie
diese Frau Sahra Wagenknecht ach das ist
für mich nicht das Wort für Menschen
wissen sie fasziniert weil ich zum
letzten Mal als Teenager von meinem
jeweiligen nein
sie hat meine Achtung das ist vielleicht
viel mehr als Faszination sie
Freundinnen geworden das kann man nicht
sagen aber wir haben wahnsinnig gut
zusammengearbeitet also was mir sehr
gefallen hat bisher bei Sarah
Wagenknecht ist dass sie ganz uneil ist
also zum Beispiel ich habe so ein
Entwurf für das Manifest gemacht dann
hat sie reagiert und ihrerseits eine
Menge reingebracht und so weiter und das
Licht zwischen uns völlig
komplikationslos fand ich sehr angenehm
weil es möglicherweise ihnen beiden auch
gleichermaßen nutzt zu dieser Zeit Frau
schwarze sie haben gerade Mut
angesprochen mit Blick auf Frau
Wagenknecht was kostet aber in diesen
Zeiten das was sie Mut nennen ist das
nicht gerade
die Fantasie was jemand wie wir der
sowas anzettelt was da los ist also also
ich kann Ihnen sagen
was kostet das kann ich denn sagen ein
Tsunami
Impfungen aber öffentlichen vor allem in
den Medien in der Politik und so weiter
aber eben auch doch die Achtung und
Sympathie der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
die sind ja immer so hingegangen
steht hinter mir zur Seite hinter uns
nicht hinter dem Kanzler das sollte ihm
zugegengegeben das haben sie im
vergangenen Jahr schon gesagt die
Umfragen sind etwa 50 müssen sagen sie
haben eine gewaltige Masse aber hinter
sich wie viele wird sich morgen zeigen
ich möchte bei dem Mut noch einmal
bleiben und sie sagen na mich kostet das
natürlich Mut weil ich eine gewaltige
Welle an Ablehnung gerade möglicherweise
Hassmails und vielleicht noch schlimmer
mich erreichen aber wäre es nicht viel
mutiger im Moment nach Russland zu
fahren auf dem Roten Platz
beispielsweise zu stehen dort im
ergressor seine Meinung zu sagen sie
machen sich schlicht lächerlich also ich
meine
Putin hat gerade auf mich gewartet
wissen sie er kennt mich überhaupt nicht
aber was soll ich in Moskau also ist ja
ab und soll ich dann wünschen sie sich
dass ich mich dahin Stelle und sage
hallo du Aggressor du Macho was er ja
ist es weiß man ja die Lage in der
Frauen in in Russland oder der Lage der
Frauen überall ist nicht so vor mir gab
aber in Russland steigt gerade die
Gewalt hat man die Gesetze die Frauen
schützen zurückgenommen das gehört
nämlich zusammen wissen Sie die Schlacht
im Schlafzimmer und die Schlacht an der
Front also mein Ansprechpartner ist
meine Regierung und ich weiß dass
Deutschland eine sehr wesentliche Rolle
spielt im Guten wie im Bösen ich glaube
auch dass die Menschen die weiter auf
Krieg und Waffen
drängen das denn vielleicht gar nicht so
unrecht ist das Deutschland geschwächt
wird und ich muss ihn auch mal sagen
irgendwann muss ja selbst dieser Krieg
zu Ende sein
darf ich mal fragen was da mit dem
Waffen ist in welchem Zustand die Männer
sind sind immer viele dann ich wollte
noch überlegen was daran mutig ist
derzeit sie sagen okay sie haben ein
bisschen mehr Ärger an der Backe haben
möglicherweise den ein oder anderen
Freund verloren der vorher ganz
wahnsinnig gerne sich mit Alice
Schwarzer getroffen hat und im Moment
einfach wahnsinnig anderer Meinung ist
aber was kostet sie das an Mut während
jeden Tag ukrainische Soldaten dort an
der Front kämpfen und sich tatsächlich
während
eigenartige Logik wissen Sie also
erstmal habe ich selber noch nie gesagt
ich bin aber mutig gut die Menschen
schreiben mir das und sie haben von Mut
gerade gesprochen aber sie meinten ihr
Mann die fest dass sein mutig was ich
will nur rausfinden das ist ja nur eine
Frage Prozent der Medien so wie sie
anzutreten das verdammt mutig wissen sie
da lesen Sie komische Sachen
Entscheidung also ich meine ich habe
jetzt ein halbes Jahrhundert
bin ich eine engagierte Bürgerin und ja
und habe mich in einer Schlachten
reingehauen wenn das richtig fand ich
muss das nicht ist doch gern bei mir auf
der Wiese und streichelt meine Katze ja
wirklich ich glaube das dauert das
glaube ich nicht ich glaube das ist das
ist genau mögen in die auseinandersetzen
Unrecht zu sehen